c'est avec cette épila que tout commence
donc on va le semer le le faire pousser
le
récolter après on va le transformer en
petite semoule de blé dur et avec cette
petite semoule de blé dur on va
fabriquer nos pâtes
en Italie que Charlie est revenu sur la
ferme familiale avec l'envie de produire
des
bio de son père un blé dur cultivé
spécialement pour le projet
on va mélanger farine et eau dans les
pétrins mélangeurs des bacs de 25 kg et
puis après on va venir ajouter ici un
moule et après derrière on va mettre un
couteau qui va découper la pâte et nous
on va on va venir étaler la pâte qui
sera à la sortie de la machine une pâte
fraîche et après on va aller là sécher
au séchoir les pâtes vont sécher à basse
température permettant de préserver
toutes les valeurs nutritionnelles du
blé après 19 heures dans le séchoir
direction lançacheuse c'est Aurore la
compagne de Charlie qui est aux
commandes
on en sache nos pâtes dans de petits
sachets de 250 à 300 g et puis ensuite
en carton de 16 unités là c'est la
destination des magasins de producteurs
des magasins bio elles sont aussi
vendues directement à la ferme bateau
piment aux lentilles ou encore au curry
chacune porte le nom d'une grand-mère de
la famille
vous avez ici la gamme Rosalie aux Noirs
à l'ail ou encore aux lentilles la
fusilis chez nous elle s'appelle Suzanne
et on a par exemple ici la forme de pâte
tracteur qu'on a appelé Simone la
dernière création en date c'est après
les vendanges que Charlie et Aurore en
ont eu l'idée
c'est une pâte en forme de grappe de
raisin qu'on a appelé la petite grappe
de raisin tout simplement pour rendre
hommage à notre région de Sancerre on a
la version blanc qui sont en fait des
pâtes nature et pour imiter le raisin
rouge on a fait une recette à la
betterave chaque mois deux tonnes de
pâtes sortent de l'atelier des
gourmandes bio avec ce projet c'est la
cinquième génération de la famille du
Puy qui travaille sur la ferme de la
Villeneuve